let's get right into audience questions
for the week one that is increasingly
coming in in different forms is would it
really be possible for the United States
to vote by mail in the 2020 presidential
election i I think one thing that's
important is you've got to reframe this
question is what it actually is which is
would all 50 states really be able to
vote by mail in the 2020 election
because you really have 50 state
elections in the 2020 presidential
election so while the debate has been
Nancy Pelosi says she wants vote by mail
in November Trump doesn't and we know
why Trump doesn't it would be bad for
Trump for more people to more easily be
able to vote Trump in fact is
essentially counting on his supporters
going out to vote but Biden supporters
not going to vote maybe because of fears
of the coronavirus we don't exactly know
where that's going to be yet in November
but for a lot of states so some states
already have vote-by-mail states that
don't what you're really talking about
you know they the right loves to make it
seem like this is this overwhelming task
how do we go from no vote-by-mail to
national vote-by-mail well if you
already have absentee ballots which as
far as I know every state or almost
every state does you have to scale up
the absentee ballot program you've got
to print more ballots in advance in some
states there are laws that say you can't
just send an absentee ballot to everyone
people have to request it and then
you're able to send it to them I've
argued that simply pointing at the
policy is not really proactive
governance instead we should say let's
pass something that this year because of
extenuating circumstances you don't have
to request an absentee ballot one will
merely be sent to you and then it's just
you know we're talking about a mass mail
campaign essentially so the issue of
getting the ballots to people could be
solved if we start dealing with it now
the issue of printing and if ballots
could be solved is if we start dealing
with it now the economic cost of the
postage is far smaller than
economic cost of the election
potentially escalating or causing a
second wave of coronavirus infection and
we've got about seven months to do it so
the answer is yes the u.s. really could
vote by mail in 2020 but you would need
to start that process now and it seems
to me that especially appearing to be
past the peak on this first wave of
coronavirus the political appetite for
doing that especially from the right is
not going to be enough to reach critical
mass now sadly if a second wave gets
going closer to the fall you then may
get a lot more people even republicans
saying we've got to do vote-by-mail we
have to expand absentee ballots to
everybody in states that have absentee
ballots instead of vote by mail it
probably will be too late by then that's
the unfortunate reality by that point
the process of printing all of the
ballots putting in place enough sort of
public information about the fact that
this is the way it's being done dealing
with the fact that many states have a
rule that you can only send an absentee
ballot to someone who has requested it
you can't just start sending them out by
then it will be too late like if we
don't deal with this if on September
25th we see that wave two of coronavirus
is exploding and we've got to deal with
this it probably will be too late by
then
the question mark right now the test
case is Ohio Ohio you might remember was
scheduled to have their primary in March
they postponed it because of the virus
said it would be done June 2nd have
since changed and said we're gonna run
sort of like a nearly month-long
vote-by-mail campaign but until April
28th but everybody has to request a
ballot again relying on this thing about
we can't just send the ballots people
have to request them so we will see in
Ohio how it works in the Democratic
primary and then we'll see if there's
the political will from states to
actually do this now what you have to
also remember is because these are state
decisions you could have a situation in
November where the states that are
likely to be Biden states do the vote by
mail and Biden wins regardless and the
states that are likely to be Trump
anyway don't set up vote by mail and
they go to trump the dif
prints maker as usual will be what is
Michigan do what does Pennsylvania do
what is North Carolina do those few
states that end up making a difference
and then it's anyone's guess this is one
area where it's good that Michigan has a
Democratic governor it's good that
Kentucky now has a Democratic governor
because it could be the difference maker
in do they vote by mail or not in
November and thus does the election flip
towards Joe Biden or back towards a
donald trump reelection scary stuff a
lot riding on it